[Music]
oh hey I'm so excited to be here guys no
big deal I just lost over 60 pounds like
all I had to do is change my weight to
the metric system and don't have to
exercise it's awesome I've been trying
to get in shape and it's so hard and
it's also so expensive to get into shape
workout clothes are so expensive like am
I gonna sweat in them or get married in
them why are they so much money I went
to this expensive workout store called
Lululemon exactly guess what I found out
I'm too fat to fit into their workout
clothes I have to lose 30 pounds before
it can work out in their stupid clothes
but I didn't want to leave the store
without buying anything so I went around
I was getting very desperate I'm like do
you have headbands key rings were like
keychains what I finally found a sports
bra that kind of fit cleaned it fit
right Santa I looked at the tag it was
50 bucks it's like 50 bucks dude that's
outrageous man $50 is so much money when
I can just go to Home Depot and hire a
day laborer to hold them up for 10 bucks
come on come on come on we're doing this
DOS me yes that's me yes come on
squeeze them I need support I can talk
about day laborers on latina unless you
hate Latinos than I'm Indian and if you
hate Indians and Latinos god you're
racist it's been a hard couple of years
for Latinos past couple of years we keep
talking about immigration and they
always talk about what a big immigration
problem we have you know and that might
be true if you ever notice that every
time they talk about immigration they
always show pictures of people that look
like me I mean last time I checked there
were two countries that boarded the
United States and I never see any Border
Patrol looking for illegal Canadians
anywhere I go you never go up to a guy
hey you with the hockey jersey are you
listening to Celine Dion where the hell
your papers Trevor
and I get it people want to come to this
country we have it pretty good here we
have so many luxuries you know I mean
we're at the point where we actually
care about what kind of life our food
had before we killed it and ate it you
go to the grocery store they want to
tell you how at the back story of every
food you know and oh this milk was
hormone free this beef was a grass-fed
this chicken was cage free dude these
animals had a better childhood than I
did I went to public school I had bars
on my window but this chicken is cage
free okay so expensive I have to pay for
the hobbies the chicken had what it was
a lot oh well this chickens delicious
it's $12 a pound because it played the
cello I'd like to surf it sounds like an
amazing chicken why are we killing it if
I had a choice to eat something that had
a privileged life screw that I need a
Kardashian
I recently had a birthday and I realized
guys that I'm at that age where the only
way I can get into a nightclub is by
telling the door guy that I'm looking
for my underage daughter but then I
realized I have to pretend to look for
the girl the entire night I'm like hey
where's Stephanie where's she's not down
here what's up
[Applause]
you